A man hunted by a shadowy enclave
of men in a male-ruled dystopia?
Let's mix it up. From ice-cold
classics to waterlogged flops,
we're playing "what if" on some
iconic sci-fi and fantasy roles.
John Carpenter's "The Thing"
was a flop at the box office,
but it became a cult classic and is now regarded
as a sci-fi horror masterpiece. It is also a film
that has zero female characters. In fact, the
only female voice in the film is a computer
playing chess against MacReady in the opening
scene, and that gets killed off pretty early.
"Checkmate. Checkmate."
Kurt Russell is certainly
legendary in the lead role,
and the film is all but perfect,
but it's fun to ask "what if?"
So imagine if MacReady was played by a woman
instead. It could have actually been great.
"The Thing" with its original cast was
excellent, but throwing a woman into the mix,
especially as MacReady, could have given the film
more complex interpersonal dynamics to explore.
Mac's paranoia would have been multiplied
by being the only woman in the wilderness,
with a group of men breaking under pressure. A
female Mac could have tackled incorrect perceived
notions that women are the overly emotional
ones, flipping that notion on its head by
being the only one to maintain a cool head
in a crisis. "Alien" did it, and "The Thing"
could have easily gone in that fascinating
direction. The 2011 prequel of "The Thing"
did feature a female in the lead role, however,
as Mary Elizabeth Winstead portrayed Kate Lloyd.
"They're not Swedish, Mac, they're Norwegian."
Kevin Reynolds' "Waterworld" was a
misfire of epic proportions - the
kind that spent the next several
years as a Hollywood punchline.
Could it have been salvaged by a female
playing a mutated loner with gills, though?
One of the film's many shortcomings was
an awkward, quasi-love story between Kevin
Costner's Mariner and Helen, which simply
didn't work. Toss that aside and start anew,
either making it a same sex romance or
re-casting the Helen role with a male,
and perhaps that chemistry could work.
It certainly couldn't be much worse.
Seeing two women work together to get
a child to the safety of dry land may
have been a more interesting and emotionally
resonant film. "Waterworld" could have been
a film about a reluctant heroine with
the courage to trust and help others
despite fears of judgment, rather than
an aloof story about an embittered loner.
"Well, it better not screw up my short game."
"Dark City" barely earned
back its production budget,
despite getting praise from critics and being
one of only a handful of films that were so
beloved by Roger Ebert that he recorded an
audio commentary for every scene of the film.
But could it have done better at the box office
with a leading lady in the Rufus Sewell role?
Considering that the Strangers are all men,
it would have been interesting to have Sewell's
Murdoch played by someone of a different gender.
The film's themes suggest we as humans have
more power in our lives than we might think.
Having a woman possess the ability to alter
her environment, and to manifest the world she
wants to live in, would have been a powerful and
surprising message for a sci-fi film at the time.
Science fiction is a genre that can give a
voice to traditionally marginalized groups.
By casting a male lead, "Dark City" missed
an opportunity to embrace the subversive,
rebellious power of science
fiction and this story.
"So it seems you've discovered
your unpleasant nature."
When "Carnivàle" premiered, it seemed
destined for greatness, winning five Emmys,
receiving positive reviews, and developing
a solid fan base. Sadly, the series lost
its audience after Season 1 concluded, limping
through the next season before being canceled.
But, if they had cast Ben Hawkins
as a woman instead of Nick Stahl,
this fascinating and influential series
might have been even more interesting.
With a female Hawkins, the show wouldn't just
have a battle brewing between good and evil
as the awesome introduction of the series sets
up. It could have explored the patriarchy pitted
against the matriarchy. "Carnivàle" could
have had plotlines based around Christianity
and the church of men, stamping out pagan
nature religions and the divine feminine. Having
Hawkins' opponent in this conflict represented by
Brother Justin Crowe already set up this dynamic.
With the suggestion that female-led
entertainment is no longer a financial risk,
this supernatural period drama could
be begging for a female-led reboot.